these are the solar power towers of
southern Spain this is one of the
sunniest parts of Europe and these were
two of the first solar towers ever built
almost 2,000 heliostats movable mirrors
constantly reflect the Sun onto the
towers heating up water into steam and
powering a turbine to generate
electricity and if you look online
you'll see quite a few documentaries
who've gotten a tour around there who
have been incredibly impressed by the
technology and I've been selling them as
the future of power generation and these
are impressive not just visually the
technology behind them is both very
clever and very simple it's like
bothering your teacher with the sunlight
reflection off your phone just on a much
much bigger scale but there is a catch
when these were built Spain was in boom
times and heavily subsidizing solar
power investors loved it and piled in
with their own money companies and
researchers were happy to set up all
sorts of things like this and suddenly
the Spanish government had many times
the amount of solar power they'd planned
for and they had to subsidize all of it
and then the financial crash hit the
Spanish government cut subsidies not
just for the future not just for the
plants or under construction but even
for the plants that were already built
and relying on those subsidies to
balance the books the industry got cold
feet
Spain had altered the deal and all the
solar companies could do was pray they
didn't alter it any further or go
bankrupt in one of the - this might
still have been viable maybe with some
more research and development and that's
what they were trying to do but now the
cost of everyday regular solar panels is
tumbling
not mirrors not like this just normal
solar panels the sort we can fit your
house or the get put out in massive
fields as solar farms converting
sunlight directly to electricity whether
the price of those panels is going to
keep falling is well it depends on which
team of researchers you believe but it's
already cheaper than building a giant
tower putting any the high-pressure
water or molten salt for it to heat and
dealing with thousands of moving parts
that all have to line up and track the
Sun perfectly and which might
occasionally cook a few birds in
mid-flight don't get me wrong this is a
great bit of technology on paper it
combines renewable energy with storage
if you're heating up something like
molten salt you can save that power
four hours to get you through the night
and there are other plants like it being
built as one nearly completed in the
Atacama Desert in South America but
right now this is expensive it might not
have been if history had taken a
different track of research had poured
into these instead of into regular solar
panels but as it is the future probably
isn't quite this right